this is my long overdue review of a
timeless eighties fantasy the labyrinth
alright so in the labyrinth Jennifer
Connelly is like 18 years old I'm gonna
say 18 because any younger than that and
I start getting creepy even though they
think she's 17 and she's a dreamer her
heads in the clouds she doesn't really
like her life namely her little brother
so one day she says I wish the goblins
would come and take you away right now
which happens to be the exact phrase you
need to say for the goblins to come and
take a baby away after that she's a bit
like oops and David Bowie who plays the
Goblin King appears with his bulge and
he says what's said is said which is his
way of saying too bad so sad and so he
says all right you want him back you
have 13 hours to solve my labyrinth get
to my castle and he's gonna become one
of us forever and I'm not talking like a
page on a book or something like that
that takes me 13 hours no this is like a
land it's a kingdom that he owns that's
a labyrinth full of magic creatures and
awesome and so she embarks and then we
have a timeless fantasy movie that is
memorable until the day you die honestly
I haven't seen this movie since I was a
little kid and I watched it like seven
minutes ago how time was gonna move
again seriously you know what I think it
is it's a fantasy movie before they
could just flood the frame in the screen
with a bunch of CGI crap everything took
time everything took heart it was back
when you made a fantasy movie you really
gave a [ __ ] all the characters are
memorable in this movie and they're like
groundbreaking when they came out
there's a big dude who calls rocks my
favorite guys with those chili down guys
who could like pull their arms off and
knock their heads off it's awesome
although that scene is the only scene
where you really notice the green-screen
like more than my green screen doesn't
change the fact that it's timeless and
they gave a [ __ ] and the lesson in the
movie is that Sarah Jennifer Connelly
she takes everything for granted and in
this place you can't it's a magical
place that's absolutely stacked against
her you cannot take anything for granted
in the labyrinth and the land like the
labyrinth is really there's a lot of
stuff to see in there everything from
dungeons to the bog of eternal stench
and yes we have the Bowie bulge this is
just what happens with David Bowie wears
really skin tight pants although I just
found out that David Bowie's sons the
one who directed source code so
something came from the Bowie bulge so
thank you boa bulbs for giving us good
movies and for scarring my eyes as a
child but this movie really is an epic
timeless movie at the end throw down
when all the goblins are coming at them
it looks a little sloppy but you get the
feeling that the goblins are just like a
bunch of [ __ ] anyway so it's not
gonna be like through the Spartans from
300 like goblins have like an airtight
phalanx or something they're supposed to
be idiots and the soundtrack is badass
in all its 80s glory I actually have the
soundtrack I feel like I'm preaching to
the choir right now because is there
anyone who subscribed to me that
actually has not seen the labyrinth if
you haven't watch it the labyrinth is
not only awesome tacular it is
timelessly awesome tacular I only say
that because every time you know you
remember a movie being good then you
watch it now and you're like it's good
there are some things that are a bit
dated the labyrinth really doesn't like
that I mean yeah some of the puppets are
a little dated but you love it every bit
as much now as you did back then I don't
know if it's because it took me back but
I like to think it's just really good
you don't see stuff like that anymore so
it's on Netflix right now you can stream
it watch the labyrinth and have you seen
the labyrinth have you seen it like now
or when you were a kid what did you
think of it what do you think of it
comment below let me know we're helping
hands but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]